hello everyone and welcome to the final
round of the 2018 bill chess festival
like I've said yesterday I'm really
looking forward to this game it's Magnus
Carlsen versus Nick oogie oogie artists
as they drew their game in the first
half of the tournament now cousin has
the white pieces he can no longer win
the tournament ESMA media have already
wanted to one whole round before the
tournament ends but you know to him to
keep keep his rating and not be the only
one who wasn't able to beat Niko in this
tournament it's very interesting what
opening he will choose so before we
check out the game we do have a nice
photo challenge before this game so
there you have it
who is the chess player in the photo
best of luck to everyone playing in the
bill open for open tournament and we do
have a nice photo of Magnus and Niko
before the game so there we have it
there's the handshake photo was taken by
Simone Bohan blues the the photo is from
the official bill chess festival website
there will be a link in the description
below if you want to check out some of
the other photos as they are all quite
quite excellent so let's check out the
game cross and opens with E 4 we have C
5 the Sicilian defense by Nico and now
comes I don't think this move was ever
played by a world champion but I could
be wrong in knife to a3 so definitely
looking for adventure it's gonna be a
very interesting game and as a Nico here
is I believe more than 300 rating points
below world champion Magnus Carlsen he
definitely does not want another draw
we have g6 Knight to f3 Bishop to g7 +
c3 now preparing d4 so Nico pushes d5
which is a the ideal responses there is
a pawn on c3 there is no longer a knight
on b1 so you know it's all all makes
sense he captures on d5 Queen captures
on d5 and now Bishop to c4 now the
knight from a3 comes very useful
Queen to e4 check and now while you can
bring the best bag Bishop to e2 you
could block with the Queen go for an
early Queen exchange Carlsen keeps
everything on the board he goes into f1
we have brush up to e6 offering a queen
trade and here comes Queen to a4 check
it really seems like like Magnus's
pushing
pushing for more than there should be in
this position and here comes Knight to
d7 you should be careful of course the
Bishop to d7 trying to kick away the
Queen would be met with Bishop captures
on f7 and black would lose the game
terribly here after King captures you
can even capture the Queen immediately
or maybe go women i g5 check and then
either capture with the knight or the
queen both is very nice of course so
after Queen to a5 a4 check nice to d7
blocking and now d4 Knight to f6 Nico
simply develops we have Bishop to g5 and
now comes the Bishop to c4 with Czech
Queen captures on c4 and now Queen to d5
and Eco offers a queen trade rook to e1
we have e six and now comes and Bishop
captures on f6 Nico blade Knight
captures on f6 of course not Bishop
captures then Queen captures on d5 wins
the game as the pony spin from the rock
on e1 so Knight captures on f6 coach is
perfectly normal
Queen to b5 check now what do you do
here tonight the d7 was played and now
nice to e5 a6 kicking the Queen away
Queen to see for Carson again offers a
queen trade Knight captures on e5 d
captures on e5 and now rook to d8 Carson
grabs the Queen Queen captures on d5
rook captures on d5 and f4 so after all
is said and done it's only move 19 but
already pretty much everything has been
exchanged and cousin has a knight on a
three against a Nico's Bishop on g7 as
the bishop on g7 isn't really doing all
that much since Carson has this a very
nice central structure and eco
immediately goes for it which is a very
nice move g5 so temporarily giving up a
pawn but it will create a lot of
weaknesses so you could go for something
like g3 not allow you to double your
opponents but then captures captures and
Bishop to h6 will make it very hard for
for white actually defended if you even
if you play something like rook to e4 to
defend it
rope the g8 is coming and it will be
very hard for for whites to develop the
rook on h1 and to play any moves in this
position so instead after g5 cross and
decides to capture at F captors and g5
and now King
seven preparing to bring the other look
into the game here h4 is played you a
very interesting variation is nice to
see forth to try and add another
defender of the e5 pawn and after b5 and
knights to b6 attacking the rook but not
even night to b6 very at Knight to a5
defending d5 pawn indirectly so now of
course if you capture then you get
Knight to c6 check black loses the game
but it it will all work out well for
black after rook to c8 and preventing
Knight to c6 check and then whatever
white plays then only next move black
will capture on e5 so Carson doesn't
butter guarding it
h4 is played we have rook captures on e5
rook captures on e5 and now Bishop
captures on e5 King to e2 preparing to
bring the other look into the game and
now b5 night to see to cousin has to
activate his Knight from a three rook to
the 8 and now Knight to e1 see for not
allowing Knight to b3 soul knife to f3
is played attacking the bishop bishop
back to g7 and now comes Knight to d2 we
have h 6 nights the e4 so a very nice
central square for Carlson's night also
it's a light first so Anika will not be
able to attack it with the Bishop H
capture Sun g5 h capture Sun g5 and now
rook to d5 the g5 point is is kind of
weak it's a double pawn Sonique would
very much enjoy capturing it and perhaps
it will he will be able to attack and
with the bishop here a3 is played by
Carson as a 5 and B 4 is to be expected
from Miko something like rook to h7 does
seem very appealing but geez g6 will
never actually become a threat King to
f8 will pretty much stopped all of Weiss
ideas with rook to h7 so instead cross
and simply prepares for a Nico's
expansion on the Queen side a three
split we have a five and now rook to e1
Bishop to e5 g3
not the not the you know easiest move to
make as it does put your other doubled
pawn on on a dark square while Nico has
a dark square Bishop on but you have to
play something and also now the King
will try to infiltrate the position
reacting to f3 and the g4 King to f8
displayed King to f3
King to g7 King to
g4 and now King to g6 an eco put his
King in front of course and spawn and g5
and now people try to attack it some
candidate moves are maybe Bishop to c7
to d8 sorry about that Bishop to c7 to
d8 and from there the rook the king and
the bishop will be attacking the g5 one
so first cousin goes to work to f1 and
now Neko goes for rook to d3 attacking
cousins g3 pawn so now the knight can't
really move
but first cousin blocks the rook rook to
f3 we have rook to d1 Neko of course it
doesn't want to trade down as there is a
very weak bond on b2 as well
Crossing goes rock to e2 defending rook
to f2 defending the pawn and now any who
brings the rook back rook to d5 9th to
d2 is played with some ideas of perhaps
pushing gay for and after an exchange
capturing and c4 but Nico immediately
goes for Bishop to c7 now there is a
double attack against the g5 pawn and
you have to defend it Knight to f3 is
played and now comes a bishop to d8
with a triple attack against cousins g5
pawn there is only one good move here
call someplace at night to h4 check
kicking the King away from from
attacking the g5 pawn king to g7 is
played and here across and simply
repeats Knight to f3 to defend the pawn
and here is a the first moment in the
game where if if Nico wanted he could
have simply continued with King to g6
and Carlsen wouldn't really have any
other choice but to go for a night to h4
check and a three-fold repetition would
have been played and a draw would have
been agreed upon but Nico
wants to push for more Bishop to b6
attacking cousins rook rook to e2 and
now comes bishop back to c7 cousin goes
rook to e4 preparing rook to d4 and here
Bishop to d6 is played a better move
would have been Bishop to b6 not
allowing Carlsen to go rook to d4
but as Nico della would cross in place
at rook to d4 rook captures Knight
captures attacking the b5 pawn and mouth
well as it is on a LightSquared there's
no way to defend it you have to push it
before and here Carlsen place a for
creating a very critical position here
where black could play so many moves
to a faith is an idea Bush of 3/5 is an
idea even capturing on c3 after
capturing then Bishop to e3 not allowing
this nice to move also an idea black
would have been perfectly fine in this
position but instead after this a4 move
Nikko played b3 b3 is a as a Nico was
not satisfied with a draw he wanted to
create something here he wanted a full
point against world champion magnus
carlsen and it does seem like it's a
very nice move for example if white
plays something like king to f3 then you
get bunch of 283 and you win this game
as there's no way for you to the
defended the b2 pawn black blade or
capture here then capture here creating
a much better position or winning
position and of course if you capture
the bishop then b2 then there's no way
of preventing the b2 upon from Queenie
another nice idea
after this b3 move is if Carlson would
for example play something like Knight
to c6 Knight to c6 wouldn't attack
against the a5 pawn then you would get
Bishop to e3 as planned but now Knight
captures on a5 Bishop character some b2
Knight captures on c4 but should capture
some c3 and after Knight 2 a 3 an eco
could push b2 and again black would be
much better here red or black would be
in a winning position here
but after Carlsen pushed a4 and Nico
pushed b3 there is a one move
Nico missed but cross and didn't miss it
across and played it almost instantly
after after a long long time of playing
this game so feel free to pause the
video here and try to find the move Nico
missed cross and played and you know I
will give it a couple of seconds for you
to decide it's it's a very nice idea but
you know feel free feel free to do it so
there you have it for those who were
able to their congratulations you have
just played the only move that wins you
the game any other game any other move
would lose you the game the move cost
plate is nice to f3 and here Nico went
into a long thing I'm pretty sure it was
like it was like 20 minutes think the
last time I checked he was thinking for
20 minutes and then after
after checking all of the possibilities
there were then he simply decided that
there is no more pointing in trying to
play this game as now he saw that the
position was lost he simply forgot how
weak the c4 pawn here was and there was
no more point in continuing this game
for example whatever he plays now even
if he tries his old idea with the bishop
to a3 which seems to be winning in every
previous variation we've seen then it
doesn't work here because now B captures
on a3 is actually possible you simply
capture it and after pawn moves here you
get nice to d2 and now there is no more
pushing the b-pawn Knight will block a
do this and it's all good for white here
on the other hand if you don't play
Bishop to e3 there's a really no good
way for you to defend the c4 pawn
whatever you play in Knight 32 is coming
capturing the c4 pawn there is no good
move for Nico here and it's simply
resign Abel on the spot so yeah a very
nice game and you know a very rare
opportunity for us to check out a game
where a world chess champion will play
let's check it out one more time after E
4 and C 5 he will play Knight to a3
against the Sicilian so yeah everything
is playable you know if you want to have
fun or if you you know just don't care
anymore which I'm sure might have been
the case it might be the case in this
game Carlson played as I think after he
lost at a game yesterday against
chocolate on mommy DRF that he was no
longer interested in this tournament and
that he thought that by creating some
unusual position that his 300-plus
rating
you know difference against Nico would
be sufficient to actually win this game
on the spot but it's never easy when you
know he is the world chess champion and
of course Nico will be the most
motivated when he plays against him but
yeah that's the game after this night we
have to remove after some 20 minutes of
you know sulking and not believing what
just happened
Nico your God is resigned to the game so
that's the game I do hope you enjoy that
I do hope you've enjoyed the entire
coverage of the bill chess festival 2018
so we're gonna
return to our Bobby Fischer series and
check out what what else we might to do
while we're waiting for some bigger
tournaments and I did prepare here let's
just check it out these are the final
standings of the 2018 bill chess
festival after all the games have been
played in first place with an amazing
amazing result seven and a half out of
ten char cleared mama Dee Aarav how he
drew two gay against Peter Svidler but
I'm pretty sure as yesterday's yesterday
his rating performance was somewhere
around twenty nine hundred and fifty
should we still around twenty nine
hundred something in second place
magnus carlsen with six out of ten
maxime Bashir with five are a five and a
half out of ten Peter Svidler five and a
half out of ten navarro w-would four out
of ten and nico your guess who could
have been two out of ten but he wanted
two and a half out of ten so now he is
one and a half out of ten but he already
draw against the world champion in the
first half of the tournament so now he
wanted to grab a full point and thus he
was the full point so yeah once again I
do hope you enjoyed it as usual you can
check two of my previous videos here
think all for watching and I will see
you soon continuing with the the Bobby
Fischer series thank you all and I will
see you soon